one article making its way around the
internet right now is a new york times
article it talks about how people are
going from big tech companies such as
google facebook apple amazon and they're
going to work in the crypto atmosphere
they're going to work on crypto projects
such as bitcoin ethereum and others
elizabeth ramirez commented on this
article basically stating that these
workers are going from one bad business
model to another without actually
realizing mark cuban came back and had
an excellent thread which i'll link in
the description of this video so you can
check it out and he describes how he
views the crypto atmosphere talks about
how he views it through an
entrepreneurial mindset stating and the
example he used was very interesting he
used the book so say you write a book on
ethics and ai
to get that book distributed you'd
either have to do it through traditional
channels or digital channels the problem
with those two is that traditional
channels you have to reprint the book
and redistribute it every single year
digitally they're very easily stolen
copied and redistributed without the
actual author getting some monetary
value back in return so where does
crypto come into this crypto comes into
this because of the use of smart
contracts and nfts he essentially said
that you can make your book an nft
you can go ahead and distribute that nft
and put within the smart contract that
you want say a 10 resale value that book
so every time that book is resold you
would get a 10 royalty of that sale this
would make books cheaper for students
more accessible and very easy to
distribute because they don't have to
use that traditional infrastructure that
is now used mark went on to discuss how
the speculation cryptos all that crypto
noise you keep hearing about and what
people really should be focusing on the
signal in crypto is the applications
being built of course where these
applications can be built from they're
going to be built from developers that
come from big tech companies the
developers and engineers that work at
apple facebook amazon are all leaving on
a daily basis go work in the exciting
crypto industry so what does mark think
that these things can actually help
these applications could probably help
everything from business processes
procedures supply chains and everything
that has to do with smart contracts
decentralization security and economics
can only help i'll put the link in the
description of this video so you can
actually check out the thread yourself
it's an amazing thread i agree with mark
state he's gone down the crypto rabbit
hole he understands what's happening in
the world and the shift in technology
that's happening right in front of our
eyes and of course merchant
entrepreneurs so he had to end the
thread with talking about how if he sees
an idea that's good he'll either start a
company around that idea or he'll invest
in one that's already been built so go
check it out and maybe hit him up if you
have an idea